what does this mean to you tonight to be
here
this story finally being told
yeah i mean it's pretty cool to be here
um and you know
yeah it's awesome
it's definitely surreal you wanna show
them how dangerous you are
[Music]
venus and serena
gonna shake up this world family was
really involved with this everybody
worked on the film how great was that to
be so involved in that even tony's son
got to work on that yeah yeah that was
great even uh my nephew was yotundi's
son she got he got to work on it as well
so i mean overall was such such a great
experience and
you know just it really we wanted to
make sure it was told the right way
how was watching will as your dad and
also seeing that how much your mom and
everyone else put into this effort i
thought was so important yeah you get to
see a lot a lot of people just know
about you know my dad who is amazing and
is amazing and no one really know knows
a lot of the work that my mom did and
just kind of just being the backbone of
the family and this kind of just tells a
little bit of all of that
i love the outfit just tell me about it
real quick because it feels like
something you wore at the u.s open right
it feels like a tennis outfit i feel
like you know it could be kind of sporty
i guess but not so it's david cuomo so
it's kind of cool
i love your daughter here tonight look
at her
thank you